PROFESSOR: With this, we
can phase the construction
of the operators that
are going to help
us build totally symmetric
states and totally
anti-symmetric
states, and understand
why we solve the problem
of degeneracy, exchange
degeneracy.
So let us look into that.
So this is called
complete symmetrizers
and anti-symmetrizers,
and anti-symmetrizers.
Permutation operators
don't commute.
So there's no hope ever of
simultaneously diagonalizing
them.
There's some of them
are not even Hermitian.
So even worse, you
cannot find that, oh,
I'm going to get a
complete basis of states,
simultaneously diagonalizing,
some permutation operators are
Hermitian.
The majority are a unitary.
The transposition operators
are the Hermitian ones.
Those you could
try to diagonalize.
But if you have the
whole permutation group,
you cannot diagonalize it.
It's just too many things
that don't commute.
But while you cannot
diagonalize these things,
you can find special states
that are eigenstates of all
of the elements of
a permutation group.
So you remember, when you say--
this is a very important point.
Whenever you say you cannot
simultaneously diagonalize two
operators, it means that you
cannot find a basis of states
that are simultaneous
eigenstates.
But it may happen that
you have one state that
is an eigenstate of all
these other things that
don't commute.
It is possible to
have operators that
don't commute and
have one state that's
an eigenstate of all of them.
You cannot have a basis that is
an eigenstate of all of them,
because they don't commute.
But one state is possible.
So we can find special states.
Special states that are
eigenstates of all permutation
operators.
So let's assume we have n
particles, each living on v,
in v, so that the n
particles live on v tensor n.
People write it like
that, v tensor n,
which is supposed to
mean v tensor v with v
appearing n times.
So here is a claim
that we're going
to postulate the existence
of symmetric states.
Those are the states
that eventually will see
are the ones physics ones.
So postulate that there are the
existence of symmetric states,
psi s, n v tensor n.
In the whole big space,
there's symmetric states.
And what is the characteristic
of a symmetric state?
The p alpha, any permutation.
Remember, alpha means all
these set of indices on psi
s is equal to psi
s for all alpha.
So the state is invariant.
So we want to see that there
is such a thing, states that
are invariant, under all
the permutation operators
that we've constructed.
This state would be eigenstates
of all the permutation
operators with
eigenvalue equals to 1.
So it's a simultaneous
eigenvector
of all these operators.
But since the permutation
operators don't commute,
you cannot expect the basis.
So if there are
symmetric states,
they cannot form a basis
in the full Hilbert space.
There must be some
smaller space.
So we should be able to
reach them by a projector
into a subspace of
symmetric states.
How about defining now
postulate anti-symmetric states.
Psi A. P alpha on psi A
should then be equal to--
what should I put?
Negative psi A.
Well, yeah, that's the
first thing we would put,
but that's pretty
problematic actually.
So even when you
postulate things,
you know, postulate means,
OK, we think they exist,
then we'll try to build them.
Here, we're trying to
postulate that there
are states that do this.
There's a little bit
of problems with this.
First obvious problem,
you say, oh well, this
is a mathematical technicality.
The identity element is supposed
to be a permutation p 1, 2, 3.
And the identity element is
not going to change this one.
So that's not good.
So suppose you have one
transposition, and changes
the state, a transposition
should produce a minus sign,
because it's anti-symmetric.
But suppose you have
now two transpositions.
You act on them with
two transpositions.
One will change its sign.
The other will change its sign.
Now the total
double transposition
is a permutation operator.
Shouldn't change the
sign of the state.
So in fact, this is untenable.
We're not even-- so even
if we postulate something,
we'd have to postulate
something that makes some sense.
And so far, it
doesn't make sense.
So what can we use?
We can use the fact that
there's some even permutations
and some odd permutations.
So we'll put the
sign factor here,
psi A. This is the only
way to solve this problem
is to put the sign factor
epsilon sub alpha associated
to the permutation.
Sometimes it's
going to be a minus.
going to be a plus.
For example, for the identity
operator, it should be a plus.
For a transposition,
it should be a minus.
So what is this epsilon alpha?
Epsilon alpha is
equal to 1 if p alpha
is an even [? transpose ?] even
or minus 1 if p alpha is odd.
So an odd permutation
is one that
has an odd number
of transpositions.
So that makes sense.
This is a way to do
this consistently.
If you have a single
transposition,
and we'll put the minus, but
if you have two transposition,
it will put a
plus, as it should.
And the identity element
is an even permutation.
Therefore, it works as well.
So this is a nice thing.
This is the only
way you can define
this anti-symmetric states,
even before we construct them.
So here are the names, and we'll
stop and build them next time.
So the symmetric
state, symmetric states
form a subspace of VN
called sym N V. Symmetric
in N states of V. The
anti-symmetric states
form a subspace of VN
called anti N of V.
And our task for next time is
to construct the projectors that
bring you down to
those spaces, analyze
what are the properties
of these spaces,
and show that it solves the
problem of exchange degeneracy,
and that requires an
extra postulate in quantum
mechanics, a postulate
for identical particles.